el objetivo de este vídeo es explorar
algunos conceptos o fórmulas que puedan
encontrar típicamente en las clases de
física tradicionales pero lo más
importante es que quiero que vean que en
realidad son ideas del sentido común
vamos a comenzar con un ejemplo sencillo
y para efectos de este vídeo vamos a
acordar que si se ve una cantidad
positiva esto implica que vamos a estar
dirigiéndonos hacia la derecha
hacia la derecha de igual manera si
tenemos una cantidad negativa entonces
implica que vamos hacia la izquierda
esto es para simplificar un poco nuestra
notación de manera que no tenga que
escribir explícitamente la dirección de
un vector ya que directamente si yo veo
una cantidad positiva implica que la
dirección es la derecha y si la cantidad
es negativa la dirección irá a la
izquierda de ese vector
imaginemos que tengo una velocidad
inicial un vector velocidad inicial que
es igual a 5 metros por segundo
esta es una cantidad positiva por lo
tanto su dirección es a la derecha son 5
metros por segundo a la derecha y además
tengo una aceleración constante que es
vector y este va a ser igual a 2 metros
por segundo al cuadrado nuevamente
tenemos una cantidad positiva por lo
tanto de la dirección de este vector va
a ser a la derecha la aceleración va a
la derecha también vamos a establecer
que esta velocidad y aceleración
constante van a durar unos 4 segundos
por lo que el cambio en el tiempo van a
ser 4 segundos lo que yo quiero saber es
qué tan lejos voy a llegar y cuál será
mi velocidad después de estos cuatro
segundos vamos a encontrar primero lo
que es la velocidad final y vamos a
hacer un pequeño diagrama acá tengo este
eje
que es el de la velocidad
y este otro eje horizontal que es el del
tiempo
lo que me indica el problema es que mi
velocidad inicial es de 5 metros por
segundo aquí está el origen 0 y vamos a
decir que aquí está mi velocidad inicial
mi vector velocidad inicial de 5 metros
por segundo que hacer cantidad positiva
va a ser a la derecha y también tengo
que después de 4 segundos 1 2 3 4
segundos
aquí los etiquetó todos los segundos
pues este va a ser mi cambio en el
tiempo y aquí después de estos cuatro
segundos quiero encontrar mi velocidad
final iniciamos en cinco metros por
segundo cuando pasa el primer segundo yo
sé que tengo una aceleración constante
de dos metros por segundo por segundo de
manera que mi velocidad pasa de cinco a
siete metros por segundo durante el
primer segundo así que mi punto en la
gráfica más o menos queda acá si yo tomo
esto y sé que mi aceleración es
constante pues voy a tener una línea
recta que describa el comportamiento de
esta aceleración bueno quizás no me
salió muy recta pero esa es la idea de
manera que lo que yo quiero encontrar
cuando hayan pasado esos cuatro segundos
teniendo esta aceleración constante
quiero encontrar cuál es la velocidad mi
velocidad final
vamos a resolver esto usando variables y
números concretos
bueno aquí comienzo desde esta parte de
mi velocidad inicial y sé que cada
segundo mi velocidad se va a incrementar
dos metros por segundo entonces qué es
lo que puedo hacer puede indicar que mi
velocidad inicial vector más el cambio
en el tiempo estos cuatro segundos que
pasaron aquí delta t
si yo multiplico está del dt por lo que
es mi aceleración lo multiplicó por mi
vector aceleración que es constante
esto me va a dar como resultado lo que
es mi velocidad final si yo estoy en
este punto de la gráfica y multiplicó la
duración del tiempo por la pendiente de
esta línea entonces voy a obtener mi
velocidad final poniendo esto en números
tenemos que mi velocidad inicial es de 5
metros por segundo más el cambio en el
tiempo es de 4 segundos por la
aceleración constante esta aceleración
es de 2 metros por segundo al cuadrado
cáncer los segundos aquí y aquí y me va
a quedar que todo esto es igual a 5
metros por segundo más 4 por 28 metros
por segundo hago esta suma y me queda
que es igual a 13 metros por segundo
esta es mi velocidad final como es una
cantidad positiva mi vector va a ir
hacia la derecha
es una pausa aquí y pensemos al respecto
espero que esto sea algo intuitivo para
ustedes iniciamos con una velocidad de 5
metros por segundo cada segundo esta
velocidad aumenta 2 metros por segundo
así que el primer segundo quedamos con 7
metros por segundo en el segundo número
2 nuestra velocidad va a ser 7 + 29
metros por segundo al tercer segundo
nuestra velocidad va a llegar a 92 11
metros por segundo aunque bueno aquí la
gráfica no está muy precisa que digamos
aquí los puntos tienen el mismo espacio
entre sí así que aquí serían 11 metros
por segundo y en el cuarto segundo
alcanzamos nuestros 13 metros por
segundo vemos que esta fórmula tiene
sentido nuestro resultado es de 13
metros por segundo y así vemos que esta
fórmula es correcta de hecho ustedes se
pueden encontrar esta fórmula en física
básica es una de las fórmulas más
conocidas la velocidad final es igual a
la velocidad inicial más el cambio en el
tiempo por la aceleración en el caso de
que la aceleración sea constante
entonces pueden ver que esto no es algo
inventado esto viene de un razonamiento
que tiene bastante sentido común y así
es como obtenemos esta fórmula otra cosa
que quiero saber es la distancia que he
recorrido durante este tiempo con esta
aceleración constante como calculo esto
recordando el vídeo anterior vimos que
la distancia recorrida es el área bajo
esta curva voy a remarcar el área
calcular que viene siendo esta forma un
poco extraña el área dentro de esta
figura va a ser la magnitud de la
distancia recorrida
durante este tiempo cómo voy a calcular
esta área
vamos a usar nuestros conocimientos de
geometría básica vamos a descomponer
esto en dos figuras un rectángulo y un
triángulo calcular el área de estas
figuras es muy sencillo tendría el área
de un rectángulo que es muy sencilla de
calcular y el área de un triángulo que
también es bastante sencillo el área
el rectángulo viene siendo qué tan lejos
llegamos sin acelerar esto es sin
acelerar que tanto hubiéramos recorrido
si nos hubiéramos mantenido con una
velocidad constante de 5 metros por
segundo durante 4 segundos y esta otra
área de aquí del triángulo es que tanta
distancia extra recorrimos con esta
aceleración constante con la aceleración
así que vamos a hacer este cálculo
tenemos que al menos en esta parte el
área del rectángulo va a ser nuestra
base 4 segundos por la altura que es de
5 metros por segundo
así que 5 por 4 20 los segundos se
anulan y me queda que son 20 metros lo
que hubiera recorrido sin acelerar y
ahora como vamos a calcular la parte de
la aceleración pues con el área del
triángulo bueno tenemos que aquí está mi
velocidad final que es de 13 metros por
segundo y esta parte viene siendo mi
velocidad inicial no olvidemos que
siguen siendo vectores y como son
valores positivos
la dirección es hacia la derecha mi
velocidad inicial fue de 5 metros sobre
segundo así que esta distancia esta
distancia de acá es la diferencia entre
estas dos cantidades que viene siendo 13
menos 5 igual a 8 metros por segundo es
lo que mide esta parte de acá la altura
del triángulo que me interesa y esto lo
multiplicó por la base que
cuatro segundos y lo divido entre dos
que es la fórmula del área del triángulo
entonces como me queda mi área del
triángulo es igual
a la mitad de mi base que son 4 segundos
por la altura que son ocho metros por
segundo estos segundos se van
8 x 4 32 32 entre dos es 16 me queda que
es de 16 metros y ahora sí tengo estas
dos áreas por lo que voy a sumar las
para encontrar mi desplazamiento total
mi desplazamiento que es un vector es de
20 metros más 16 metros
usemos los colores adecuados
y esto va a ser igual a 36 metros
y ahora vamos a realizar estos mismos
cálculos pero usando variables lo que
nos va a llevar a otra fórmula muy
conocida entonces quedamos que el área
del rectángulo es el cambio en el tiempo
multiplicado por la altura que en este
caso es mi vector velocidad inicial esta
parte es el área del rectángulo por eso
lo subrayo en verde como el rectángulo y
a esto le voy a sumar el área del
triángulo que es la mitad de la base que
es la diferencia en el tiempo por la
altura del triángulo que es la
diferencia entre la velocidad final y la
velocidad inicial esto por la velocidad
final vector menos el vector de
velocidad inicial esta parte de acá
corresponde al área del triángulo y todo
esto me da el desplazamiento realizar
vamos a simplificar esto vamos a
factorizar el desplazamiento en el
tiempo
y esto va a multiplicar a mi vector
velocidad inicial más la mitad que va a
multiplicar a mi vector velocidad final
- este un medio que multiplica a este
menos velocidad inicial ahora de todo
esto lo simplificó esta velocidad
inicial la restó con este menos un medio
de velocidad inicial y esto me va a
quedar como el cambio en el tiempo que
multiplica a la mitad de mi vector
velocidad inicial más la mitad de la
velocidad final vemos que podemos
factorizar este un medio de aquí ya que
es un término común así que me queda
esto el cambio en el tiempo por un medio
de la velocidad inicial más la velocidad
final y esto que viene siendo pues esto
realmente es el promedio de la velocidad
final y la velocidad inicial esto de
aquí lo podemos definir como la
velocidad promedio velocidad promedio
hay que tener mucho cuidado porque solo
podemos usar esto como velocidad
promedio cuando tenemos una aceleración
constante si la aceleración fuera varía
y en lugar de tener una línea como
aceleración tuviéramos una curva y
entonces ya no podríamos usar esta
fórmula y finalmente tenemos la fórmula
de la distancia que es igual al cambio
del tiempo por la velocidad promedio que
quedamos que es la mitad de la suma de
la velocidad inicial más la velocidad
final esta es una fórmula muy conocida
para el cálculo de la distancia o
desplazamiento y para que vean que esto
viene de un razonamiento lógico del
sentido común para que no tengan
necesariamente que memorizar ahora si
calculemos cuál es la distancia
recorrida en ese caso como tenemos una
aceleración constante podemos encontrar
la velocidad promedio la velocidad
promedio es igual a la mitad del vector
velocidad final o la velocidad inicial
el orden no importa que es 13 más la
velocidad inicial que es de 5 metros por
segundo esto es igual a 18 entre 2 que
es igual a 9 metros por segundo este es
mi velocidad promedio que vendría
estando más o menos por acá en la
gráfica
recordemos que hacer una cantidad
positiva la dirección de este vector va
a ser hacia la derecha y al usarla en
esta fórmula que acabamos de encontrar
de deducir la multiplicó por la
diferencia en el tiempo que fueron 4
segundos de manera que me quedan 9 por 4
36 36 metros los segundos se cancelaron
y así llegamos al mismo resultado del
primer método que usamos aquí